a quite a muddled situation there and
certainly difficult to understand for us
Germans let alone for outsider so let's
ask someone who can shed some light on
the issue Claudia Kemper joins us today
she's an energy expert at the diw German
Institute for Economic Research welcome
to our show now first of all of course
the question how dramatic is the
situation in Germany really are we
looking towards some kind of blackout no
we don't the situation is not dramatic
we have an oversupply of electricity at
the moment we have enough capacities as
coal there's gas we have still nuclear
so this is also the reason why the price
is so low and the margins the profits
for the companies are very low but this
will change in the future when nucleus
going down and also called supply will
decline you just said we have goal and
gas now the energy Giants those big
energy providers like rwe or ian are now
threatening that they might shut these
power plants down what happens then what
I want to get some money from the
government let's say it's frankly
because right now they have lower gains
but it cannot be that the consumers in
Germany the electricity consumers are
paying for those difficult situations
because it will change and the companies
know that we will have enough capacities
and this obviously is the market and
this is how it works how did we get into
this situation I mean it seems to be
rather complex there is one energy grid
and various energy providers and
somebody obviously feels left out I mean
who is at fault here well we have the
increase of renewable energy at the
moment and we still have coal power
plants and nuclear power plants and what
the conventional power producer do is
that they construct new coal power
plants and now we have an oversupply and
this is the reason why the price of the
stock exchange for wholesale prices
declining and this brings the profits
down but there is obviously a Miss
development and this for change in the
future how can it change and who's going
to change it well the nuclear power
plants will be shut down this is
politically decided and as
major energies providers will they
change tactics eventually or well
hopefully they will because the future
of the German in a given that the energy
transition is to have a higher share of
renewable energy and to have gas fired
power plants until the companies are
asked to increase the share of gas
because it can be better combined to
renewable energy now the key to it of
course is to have mixed energy in the
meantime what does the German government
need to do to achieve that well the
German government I want to have this in
a gear change the energy change energy
vendor and therefore we need to have an
increase of renewable energy the grid
needs to be expanded we need to do more
for energy efficiency and we need gas
fired power plants are therefore there
will be a whole change and we need a
good market structure to have all this
and finally how will all of this affect
the consumer what what will happen to
the price all right now the wholesale
price is very low but the consumer does
not feel it because it's just increasing
at the moment because of feed-in tariffs
for renewable energy is increasing
hopefully the electricity price will be
stable but it will definitely be a
decline we decline in the future because
we have a complete change okay Claudia
comfort thank you very much for joining
us today thank you